it's great to be joined today by Michael
Lynch who's the director of the
humanities Institute professor of
philosophy at the University of
Connecticut also author of the new book
know-it-all society truth and arrogance
in political culture
Michael so great to talk to you thanks
so much for having me
this is such an interesting topic to me
the idea of the sort of combination of a
much longer period of pseudo and anti
intellectualism which has sort of
combined with or crashed with this
intellectual arrogance trend that we're
seeing partially because of the internet
and social media can you first just talk
a little bit about what are some of the
ways that internet and social media have
made people intellectually arrogant well
when we talked about first of all just
you know when we talk about intellectual
arrogance what I mean is the idea of
being resistant to improving your
worldview by appeal to evidence or to
the experience of other people it's the
idea that you know you know it all and
that your your your worldview is at
least with some respects unimprovable
and I think there are pretty obvious
ways that all of us are really
intimately familiar with in which the
Internet
and the ways in which we use the
Internet can reinforce and encourage
this attitude I mean for one thing you
know no matter what your opinion you may
have on any topic you can google and get
some confirmation for that opinion from
some corner of the internet dark or not
and in a way you know right now it used
to be that scene was believing we'd say
but now googling is believing and
therefore you know getting information
in that way the sort of weird
paradoxical fact is that our ability to
get information in the in that way so
easily right at our fingertips is also
not not just making us in a sense feel
more knowledgeable but feel that we we
are always right because of the ability
to confirm our biases I mean one
add one other element to that which is
that the Internet is a personal
personalized information seeking device
as or set of devices and platforms
everything that we encounter on the
internet from the news that comes down
our Facebook feed to the ads that we see
on the pages we visit are all
personalized and of course that's great
when we're shopping for books or shoes
or what-have-you it's not so great when
we're shopping for facts because if
you're just getting the facts that
confirm your pre-existing prejudices
that's a you know short road to type of
epistemic disaster yeah there are some
elements to the social media platforms
the the way you're talking about
algorithmically and otherwise which sort
of encourage or perpetuate a sort of
reasoning from emotion and style rather
than facts but but beyond that is there
something about social media and the
internet that just beyond the algorithms
does encourage people to be arguing more
from emotion rather than from fact yeah
I think there is I think that one of the
things that we besides the sort of
algorithms and the personalization one
of the things that I think is really
motivating this rise that we see in a
type of arrogance and including what I
would call as type of tribal arrogance
is that we're often unaware of how we're
communicating on social media we're sort
of in a sense blind to to the real
nature of our communicative acts here's
an example when you share when we all
share something online
that's a news story whether it's fake or
otherwise when we share some piece of
news content you know from The Guardian
or or from this show or what have you
you think of yourself as at least I do
as like sharing some piece of you know
factual information or at least saying
you know here's some interesting opinion
that you should probably pay attention
to and I'm saying that to my my friends
or followers yeah
so it looks like I'm engaging in sort of
the game of you know giving reasons and
so forth but really
it seems like we might be doing
something else so one reason to think
that is because a lot of data is coming
out right now that show that's something
that we probably all intuitively know
which is that almost no one that shares
things online reads what they share what
what that that suggests something it's
just really not we're doing something
else we're communicating in some other
way and what I think we're often doing
is what we're doing is signaling that
well we're a member of a particular
tribe or group we're saying we're on
this team and weren't sober and we're
communicating in other words a sort of
emotional feeling and it or perhaps
we're communicating a sense of outrage
and of course the platforms are
hardwired to encourage this sort of
thing the sorts of you know the treats
again things that most of people
listening here are going to know is that
the more sort of emotional language you
include in your tweet or your post the
more sort of a language of outrage you
include the higher the likelihood that
that will be reposted Reshard or
retweeted and that fact alone suggests
that the whole economy of social media
is encouraging us to engage in this sort
of expression of sentiment if I was
David Hume the philosopher would called
it or emotion and the fact that we're
not aware that we're actually doing that
makes us really easy marks
yeah well this starts dovetail with
findings from such you know varied
academic disciplines as what Jonathan
height has written about in moral
psychology what Daniel Kahneman has
written about in behavioral economics
that in many times we simply we believe
that we have come to our conclusions
based on the evidence when in reality
we've often come to our conclusions for
other reasons height would say it
relates to our moral values that that
resonate more with us Daniel Kahneman
would have more of a logistical
practical behavioral economics approach
but that we are first coming to our
conclusions then finding information to
justify them and that's where I think
social media has really
scaled-up this mechanism yeah it's a
it's definitely a device a mechanism as
you just said to fuel confirmation bias
I mean there's been a lot of research as
most of the listeners will probably know
about the sort of bubbles the
information and epistemic bubbles that
we live in that is fueled by the
personalization we talked about and also
encouraged by the the hardwiring of the
platforms as I was talking about them to
encourage the emotional exchange over
informational exchange I mean I think
what we're finding is that both the
economy of social media and our
psychology are human psychology are just
working together and forming a sort of
toxic mix that's included increasing
this type of arrogance that we're
talking about of course you have to add
to that politics ideology right now in
our country there is an increasing there
are ideologies that are starting to
celebrate the idea that fat facts and
reason and that experts and science
celebrate that those things should not
be listened to and that you should trust
your gut and that you should trust your
child and that it's the tribe that gives
power and it's not something we're not
answerable to the facts that that
ideology together with the psychology
that we've already we're just talking
about and the technology that's a real
toxic mix and it's really leading to
what I'm calling the know-it-all society
so that's what I wanted to talk about
next which is what what do we know
empirically or quantitatively about the
partisan divide on some of these
phenomena because for example there are
many reports which say if you look back
at the 2016 election the amount of
actual fake news not using the
definition of the current President but
actual just straight fake news that was
shared was significantly higher by
conservatives than by liberals as one
example of showing that this phenomena
is not
sort of taking root equally across
partisanship what can you add to our
understanding of the partisan element to
this a sort of cultural element that
you've identified the know-it-all
society okay well you know when we think
about polarization so let's step back a
little bit and think about what you know
common topic of conversation in
conversations like this which is that
you know we're polarized recent data for
example from pew suggests that on a
break range of issues on actual issues
if you pull people who are both
conservative leaning conservative of
liberal leaning and liberal you find
surprisingly well of course Americans
are you know strongly divided on a whole
number of issues there's actually much
more agreement that you might
antecedently think yes at the same time
at the same time there is increasingly a
dramatic increase in polarization of
what we might call effective polity
polarization are Group polarization that
is we are more and more prone to
describe the people on the other side of
the aisle as distrustful as
untrustworthy as immoral as ignorant and
we increasingly know that the other side
describes us whoever the other us is in
the same way and we resent them for it
that so the first thing I think to keep
in mind is that there's a sort of
there's a growing awareness that we that
we are sort of polarized in this way and
there's a strong resentment and tagging
ISM that's fueling being fueled
precisely from that awareness now to get
back to your question about how these
different ideologies both on the left of
the right respond or or react to that I
think in in very different ways there's
no doubt right now at least in my mind
that many of the ideologies on the one
on the right
particularly ideologies that are driven
by nationalism and white nationalism in
particular our ideologies that are
self-consciously celebrating a reject
of what we might have called rational
authority that's part of what's fueling
some of the enthusiasm I think that we
see from from particular advocates of
that ideology online the thought is and
we see it I think and indeed by the
inhabitant of the White House I mean if
you want to talk about arrogance it
seems like exhibit number one of course
is Donald Trump a man who after all has
been known to say that he's the humblest
person that he knows look I think it's
not so it's not I think it is surprised
most of the your listeners that that
white nationalism is a view as a view
according to which you know whites are
superior they they whites intrinsically
no more or better people that sort of
nonsense that's clearly an attitude
that's symbolized by or in embodies as
type of arrogance that I've been
discussing and I think that the degree
to which that continues to be propagated
is the degree to which we're going to
see an increase increasing sort of
affective polarization that we're
talking about before on the other hand I
also want to point out that look it's if
you want to look up intellectually
arrogant in the dictionary you're
probably going to find a picture of a
face very much like mine I mean I'm a
I'm a white male liberal progressive
college professor to a lot of people in
the country I you know I I embody
intellectual arrogance and I imagine
some of the people listening I've
probably been thinking that fair enough
I think it's important that progressives
realize that we are not immune to
implicit bias we are not immune to the
sort of problems that are inherent human
psychology that afflict the rest of
mankind so to speak progressives I think
we and I am I have been guilty of this
and some of your listeners might think
I'm kind of guilty of this already and
this is that you can fall into thinking
that well conservatives you know they're
all like they all they all fall into the
same buckets they are the ones that have
prejudice and bias and we are the we are
the tribe of reason and rationality and
that we are free of those things that's
a mistake
it is falling into the same type of
tribal arrogance that were there you
know I for one am trying to combat so I
will frequently somewhat frequently get
phone calls from viewers who will say
hey David you know a couple years ago I
fell into an alt right sort of echo
chamber I was watching some gaming thing
on YouTube which led me to stefan
molyneux and then ben shapiro and that
woke a what they describe the path in
and they say they bought into it
completely and then the algorithm showed
me a left-wing gamer which brought me to
you and to you know they'll name other
people that do what I do and now I'm out
I'm out I've sort of been deprogrammed
from that and of course my initial
reaction is okay that's the outcome is a
good one as far as I see it but is there
not a bigger problem here that merely by
clicking around on YouTube you were
first pulled to the extreme right and
then merely by chance you became pushed
to the extreme left - I hear the way to
malleable nature of so many people's
thinking and I'm curious what your
reaction is to those stories of
radicalization and D radicalization
which even if we like the way that the
outcome went to me signal a sort of
problem plot problematic deeper problem
that's a really interesting point like
you of course I celebrate people
becoming D radicalized yes nicholae from
violent nationalists
ideologies but I also agree that what
that sort of antidote or story
illustrates is the passiveness by which
most of what you know the passive way in
which most of us seem to know nowadays
much of what we know we Google now is I
I was talking about earlier that's how
most people today receive most of their
social of their information and while
again
that can be really super useful I Google
no all day every day it's also I think
changing the way we interface with
information and how we critically
evaluate it I think that one of the
things that one of the things that I I
talk about in the book is some lessons
from some very ancient philosophical
figures including going back all the way
to Socrates Socrates one of the things
that's really interesting about the
lessons you can glean from the end of
his life is that he was somebody was
interested in questioning both authority
and and himself he said well you know
one of the things that I really the only
thing I really can say I know is that I
don't know very much and he was keen of
course to sort of bring down the people
who claim that they know quite a bit
about things and he was like - he took
some pleasure clearly and in in getting
them to admit that they didn't know as
much as they did and that's great but he
also wanted us to focus on her own
attitudes and he thought that in order
to do that you needed to get outside on
the street literally and start talking
to people to start having conversations
I think there's something to be said
with that attitude not so much is that
you can't talk people to people online
like we're doing right now that's
perfectly I think Socratic what Socrates
I think was really pushing us there was
to think of ourselves not as passive
just suckers of information but as
active inquires people who get out and
try to you know read engage talk to one
another in question question assumptions
and as I said continue to question
yourself and your own your own biases
and prejudices that you might not have
been aware that you actually have very
very good advice for sure and if only it
was taking place if only it was easier
to make that the reality based on how a
lot of these online platforms are
deliberately configured to really
generate the opposite we've been
speaking with Michael Lynch who's author
of the new book know-it-all society
truth and arrogance in political culture
Mike
really a pleasure having you on today
thanks so much it was great